[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de Francia 24 un
informe de más de 300 páginas explicó
Cómo la violencia física y emocional es
un mal sistémico en el fútbol femenino
de Estados Unidos la investigación
independiente con más de 200 testimonios
evidenció tocamientos amenazas abusos
sexuales y comentarios abusivos contra
la capacidad deportiva intelectual y
hasta parental de las jugadoras el tema
muestra de que las ganadoras del mundial
y Quienes más títulos han traído a su
país se ponen una camiseta enlodada por
la violencia machista vamos a conversar
sobre estas denuncias y sus
implicaciones para ello vamos al
contexto
el abuso físico y emocional es
sistemático en la Liga Nacional femenina
de fútbol profesional de Estados Unidos
Esa fue la conclusión de la
investigación independiente solicitada
por usaker la federación de fútbol hace
un año después de que un informe en el
sitio web de athletic describiera
acusaciones de abuso de las jugadoras
estamos enojadas porque tomó una
investigación de un tercero estamos
enojadas porque tomo un artículo en
deathletic Y de Washington post y muchos
otros estamos enojadas porque se
necesitaron más de 200 personas
compartiendo su trauma para llegar a
este punto
capitana de Estados Unidos pidió la
salida de quienes no protegieron a las
jugadoras momentos antes de su
intervención se conoció que Mary polson
propietario de su equipo los Portland
thorns dijo que se retiraría de la toma
de decisiones hasta que se lleve a cabo
una investigación Y es que el informe
dijo que el club interfirió con el
acceso a los Testigos e intentó impedir
el uso de el documento relevantes la
organización tampoco hizo acusaciones
públicas del abuso contra un entrenador
después de rescindir su contrato en 2015
y Us Soccer y la liga femenina no la
impidieron entrenar en otro lugar el
documento también mencionó al
propietario de Chicago
redsler y dejó Claro que no se
implementaron medidas básicas para
prevenir la violencia
prometió reformas
he sido parte de este juego toda mi vida
desde la juventud hasta el nivel
profesional y a nivel internacional Así
que el fútbol femenino realmente
importante para mí y conozco a muchas de
las jugadoras de este informe muchas de
ellas las entrené encontré todo el
informe impactante me pareció realmente
enloquecedor que las jugadoras tuvieran
que pasar por esto en la previa de un
juego contra Reino Unido en el estadio
de wembley y con la boletería agotada la
delantera y activista Megan dijo desde
Londres que el reporte de Estados Unidos
es solo una muestra de prácticas que
suceden en todo el mundo
aquí no salió ningún informe pero estoy
segura de que podría haber uno al igual
que podría haber uno en cada país lo
cual es una realidad realmente triste
enfatizó en la rabia y el agotamiento de
las jugadoras por los casos que son un
foco de trauma y revictimización
la conversación sobre estos casos es con
Alexandra Gómez asesora jurídica de una
organización sindical internacional hay
que agremias sindicatos de futbolistas
en todo el mundo se conecta con nosotros
desde Países Bajos Alexandra gracias
usted por estar con nosotros bienvenida
a ellas hoy y el periódico del país si
tú entre muchos de los casos del
documento el de Christie Holy el
director deportivo del Racing Louisville
de la liga de fútbol femenino
estadounidense en 2021 convocó a su
jugadora aéreo en Simón para ver el
video de uno de los partidos y le dijo
que la iba a tocar por cada vez que
hubiera fallado un pase eso es la
normalidad en el deporte las jugadoras
son intimidadas y violentadas por temor
a que no las convoquen hablemos de eso
Hola qué tal Muy buenas tardes Para
todos un placer estar aquí con ustedes a
pesar de que bueno el tema Obviamente
que es duro es duro de digerir una
situación como esta Pero la realidad es
que afipronales sorprende nosotros hace
tiempo que venimos relatando que esto es
lo que sucede en el fútbol a nivel
mundial no es una situación particular
de Estados Unidos es muy positivo que
exista este informe Más allá de lo
fuerte y lo impactante que es leerlo
para que se ponga el tema sobre la mesa
de una vez por todas Esto no es ajeno a
otros países
me animaría a decir que probablemente si
hacemos una investigación a fondo en
cada una de las federaciones miembro de
de Fifa vamos a encontrar algún caso de
acoso o abuso sexual o de inconducta
sexual tanto por parte de entrenadores
como de otro personal dentro de los
clubes ligas federaciones etcétera desde
fistro ya hemos tenido
experiencia representando jugadoras de
distintos países en situaciones muy
graves de acoso de abuso y de conducta
sexual y por eso es que no no nos llega
a sorprender este informe Pero pero
bueno no deja de ser muy duro
revisarlo y ver los detalles
Especialmente cuando viene de un país
donde realmente se espera que haya
determinados estándares que quizás en
otros países uno espera menos Pero
sabemos que si pasa esto en Estados
Unidos las chances de que exista en
otros países es muy muy alta son
altísimas y ya que no hablamos de este
tema a nivel mundial recordamos la
advertencia que hizo Megan rapinó que la
veíamos en el informe diciendo que
aunque no haya reportes en otros países
no significa que no existan los casos y
no podría estar más de acuerdo con usted
para no ir más lejos vimos hace poco la
renuncia de jugadoras en España hemos
visto casos en Argentina hemos visto
casos en Colombia todos ligados a
discriminación y violencia machista y a
violencia de género entonces
realmente existe existe la posibilidad
de proteger a las jugadoras porque aquí
no estaríamos si no fuera por estas
mujeres que decidieron dejar de salir al
campo que decidieron empezar a hacer una
denuncia pública algo que a propósito
Alexandra no es fácil hacer una denuncia
para una mujer víctima es de las cosas
más difíciles que hay Porque como quedó
demostrado en el informe el sistema no
está a nuestro favor
no por supuesto por supuesto Esta es una
de las cosas que que en las que
necesitamos ahondar hay que ahondar en
educación en educación a la jugadoras a
los clubes a las ligas pero también a
quienes trabajan en el mundo del fútbol
para que se comprenda que no son casos
como se lleva otro tipo de casos a nivel
del fútbol cuando estamos entre una
situación de acoso abuso sexual que es
muy difícil para la víctima hablar que
realmente son verdaderas heroínas todas
estas chicas que que decidieron salir
adelante y decir bueno miren a mí me
pasó esto y esto y no quiero decir con
eso que las que no lo hicieron No lo son
es muy difícil atravesar una situación
de estas y muchas veces la gente desde
el desconocimiento total dicen Bueno
pero bueno porque no hablaron antes
etcétera y acá estamos hablando de
situaciones que generan un trauma que a
veces realmente inhibe la posibilidad a
esas jugadoras de hablar y salir
adelante entonces por eso es tan
importante tener sistemas muy bien
diseñados con mucha transparencia que
todas las jugadoras los conozcan donde
se pueda reportar donde se reporte puede
hacer confidencial que pueda ser
expeditivo porque tampoco me sirve si yo
soy jugadores estoy atravesando una
situación así que yo haga la denuncia y
que después se tome una decisión en los
tres años Obviamente que eso no es
suficiente para mí como jugadora que sea
abusada ni para mis compañeras que
quizás van a seguir siendo abusadas
mientras el órgano decisor toma la
decisión determinada entonces hay un
montón de cosas en las que trabajar pero
consideramos desde filtros que quizás lo
primero es la formación la formación
hasta a las mismas jugadores de donde
comienza el acoso y el abuso Dónde están
los límites
en el fútbol femenino Lamentablemente ha
estado tachado de mucho machismo
históricamente y hay condu que sean
normalizado de cierta forma y no son
normales entonces si yo empecé a
entrenar desde muy chica con un
entrenador que me trató de una cierta
forma es muy difícil para mí como
jugadora cuando llegó a la adultez poder
hacer una distinción y decir Bueno pero
eso está malo no está mal porque eso me
lo hicieron toda la vida y eso pasa en
todas partes Alexandra pero mire sobre
eso quisiera que profundizáramos un poco
más porque se tienden generar la
trivializar el acoso y el maltrato y más
aún en un ambiente deportivo que puede
llegar a ser tan recio y en el que las
mujeres han estado tratando de alcanzar
un estatus igualitarios de los hombres
cosa que no ha sido posible de hecho
Estados Unidos ha hecho historia con ese
tema logrando condiciones laborales
mucho más justas para las deportistas
pero pero esto no se puede trivializar
entonces claro quien le vea la noticia
por encima podría pensar que claro les
hablaron duro No les gustó les dijeron
algo que les pareció ofensivo pero no lo
era y no el informe lo que nos dice es
que sí hubo conductas inapropiadas
sexualmente inapropiadas verbalmente la
proteína apropiadas y por eso quisiera
preguntarle a Alexandra que otras
vejaciones quedaron en evidencia en este
reporte aquí estamos pues para que la
denuncia quede más expandida y que la
gente entienda realmente la gravedad del
asunto
por supuesto o sea el tipo de conductas
que se describe es sumamente variado Y
como decía antes es el tipo de conductas
que vemos en otros casos también
entonces va desde la inconducta sexual
que a veces son algunos comentarios
sexistas
insinuadores
sugiriendo cosas a las jugadoras
totalmente inapropiadas sexualmente los
chistes a veces sexuales repetidos las
insinuaciones bueno todo ese tipo de
actitud
por otro tipo de conductas como enviar
por ejemplo fotografías
desnudos
solicitarle a las jugadoras que envíen
fotografías bueno el tocar a las
jugadoras esa parte también es sumamente
delicada y es un poco lo que hablaba
antes de A qué estoy acostumbrada desde
que soy pequeña cuando comencé a
hacer futbolista no es que la cosa está
normalizado de Alexandra o sea ahí no
hay nada que hacer Mire ya nos quedamos
Lamentablemente sin tiempo yo quisiera
hacerle muchas preguntas y la última que
le tengo que hacer que no quisiera que
se nos quedara por fuera Muy rápidamente
Por qué durante tantos años las
autoridades han guardado silencio sobre
estos abusos una de las explicaciones
por ejemplo quedaban algunos medios de
comunicación era el temor de Us Soccer a
recibir demandas de los entrenadores en
una situación económica que tal vez él
no era la mejor al menos para para la
liga femenina Entonces por qué los
intereses ahí que se atravesaron para el
silencio
bueno Esto es lo mismo es lo que vemos
en general Son estructuras conservadoras
que no quieren asumir que cometieron
errores porque aquí hay responsabilidad
de todas las organizaciones hay
responsabilidad de Uber hay
responsabilidad de la liga hay
responsabilidad de los clubes hay
responsabilidades individuales de
personas determinadas dentro de los
clubes Entonces el problema es que no se
quiere asumir la responsabilidad porque
no se y no se dan cuenta de que quedan
mucho peor cuando no toman acción y
luego salta un escándalo como este
entonces realmente la invitación a que
cada persona que hasta escuche un rumor
sobre un tema de acoso abuso sexual que
investigue que reporte y bueno y y
decirle a las jugadoras de todo el mundo
que acá estamos desde fistro para
apoyarlas en cualquier situación que
estén pasando así que siempre se pueden
contactar con nosotros en fistro.org que
es nuestra Website así que cualquier
situación Aunque quizás tengan dudas
siempre pueden haber con nosotros para
para poder esclarecer y siempre van a
tener nuestro apoyo No pues muchas
gracias Alexandra Porque de eso se trata
ya para el cierre simplemente el
comentario de la presidenta de la
federación de fútbol femenino sin
deparlow que se declaró horrorizada y
profundamente preocupada por las
declaraciones y sin embargo causa
curiosidad y puede ser más un ejemplo de
esta normalización Pues que ella estuvo
ahí en primera persona y lo vivió como
jugador y como entrenador entonces
pregunta uno por qué hasta ahora tiene
que causar esa indignación Muchas
gracias a usted Alexandra Gómez de Fish
pro y a nuestros televidentes por estar
con nosotros Nos vemos Próximamente en
ellas hoy
[Música]